(music)
- [Jodi Hauptman] Leopold
Survage created this series
called Colored Rhythm.
He had this idea about
making abstract film,
this idea that Survage himself said
to throw off paintings last shackle,
and that is immobility,
making painting move.
And part of that was related to
other kinds of movement happening in the
ever growing cities at that moment.
The invention of the automobile,
the airplane, the incredible
spectacle of the city,
the lights, and even the
beginnings of cinema,
which first began in 1893, so when Survage
is thinking about making his film,
it's only about 20 years in.
He turned to the thing he knew best,
and that was drawing.
He chose a very smooth paper.
there was no resistance
from bumps or bulges.
He started with a black ink.
He created a shape around
the edges of the picture
and then he filled it in with these
very beautiful washes of watercolor.
Ink is not water soluble.
And then when he went back
in with the water color,
it would stay in place.
And that allowed him to create
these beautiful washes one after another.
He captured one of the
primary qualities of cinema,
and that is light.
They have a kind of glow, a luminosity
that is not dissimilar from what you see
when you're sitting in a movie theater.
When you lay out the series, you see how
one shape feeds into another
shape into another shape.
Some of the critics at the time
who knew these drawings,
talked about the relationship
to something organic, to plants,
things that swell and grow and deflate
and grow again.
He made over 100 drawings with the idea
that eventually technicians
would actually animate them.
He understood that he
himself couldn't do it,
but unfortunately, because of the
onset of World War 1, the
film was never actually made.
He was trained as a painter,
a very traditional
painter, but his ability to
think outside of that training
and to imagine something
that he didn't have any idea
of how to make is just an
incredible act of risk,
that I think is crucial for this moment.
The best artists are those that were
able to take risks.